and this is the epicenter of black
economic achievement over the years and
the fact that it's not here now today
what's left causes some of the
challenges that you're talking about
right now
[Music]
can you believe it i'm still here living
inside this tent for 100 days from
november 20th to february 28th bring to
you the issues and awareness that you
need to know about the violence on the
south side of chicago but also to raise
as much money as we possibly can to
build a community center on this much
needed block called o block it's called
oh block because it's named after a
young man named od perry who was shot
and killed the gangs took the o in his
name and started calling it oh block we
decided we're going to keep the o but
we're going to change it to opportunity
block i want to thank fox network for
giving me the opportunity every single
day to bring to you rooftop revelations
where i share with you my thoughts
viewpoints and opinions on matters as it
relates to chicago and things across our
great country i'm really thankful today
to have a very astute and intelligent
brother with us today to talk about
something that is very near dear to my
heart and that's business
entrepreneurship so i want to welcome
bruce montgomery who teaches all the
entrepreneurship classes at project hood
and who is an entrepreneur himself uh
bruce welcome hey glad to be here pastor
thank you man listen i want to
just
jump right in in chicago we're dealing
with a lot of violence yes we are
everybody knows the reason why i'm on
this roof is because of the violence
that's right and somebody who's watching
is going to say what does
entrepreneurship
have to do with stopping violence
uh entrepreneurship has everything to do
because we know that
where there is wealth
where there is commerce
where there is
goods credit
scores yes you don't see uh challenges
in education poor health outcomes uh
lack of vision for opportunity you if
you can't see it you don't think about
being absolutely so when we had the most
famous entrepreneurs black entrepreneurs
in the entire united states yeah was in
a one two three four mile radius of this
rooftop yeah this is
you know the the height of the great
migration and what became known as
bronzeville the height of that was in a
one two three four mile range where
woodlawn yes and this is the epicenter
of black economic achievement over the
years and the fact that it's not here
now today what's left causes some of the
challenges that you're talking about
right now man let's talk about that
because a lot of people i know i'm
always learning about woodlawn and i'm
always learning i learned some things
just this past week about this location
how it was an epicenter for a lot of uh
entrepreneurship and businesses and
black businesses in our community and i
want to ask you a question
there was a time when
businesses were thriving
in this area i mean booming yes but now
as you just said
there's nothing
how do we get from
having all of these businesses
to now having nothing because i think
that contributes to a lot of the
violence that we see every single day
well when we think about some of the
legendary entrepreneurs um there was a
place down the street called robert's
motel yeah yeah mr roberts just passed
just uh a year or so ago i bought our i
bought my church building off from
history okay
that roberts motel
was the
meeting place yeah that's where harold
washington went to have conversations
about should he run that's where mr
collins got together and said he was
going to start
a seaway bank that's where
arguably one of the most illustrious
black entrepreneurs that used to operate
right off of 63rd street sb fuller
uh fuller products full of products was
right here right walking distance from
where we are right now and so what
happened is
as
redlining restricted covenants that
limited where blacks could move live
work and own
meant that we in woodlawn and this
surrounding area we were focused on
meeting our own needs ourselves
so we mr collins had grocery stores the
food basket
uh he went on established seaway bank
where blacks could bank and some of the
first black businesses could get a
business loan from a black bay we had
transportation companies we had black
cab companies we had jitney all of this
was meeting our own niece didn't nobody
know what a jitney was other than on
south park or king drive right jitney's
only ran up and down cottage bro you
know and then all of the the arts and
entertainment that was lost right not
too far from here is one of the great
theater facilities that used to be just
a block over from here on the parkway
yes
so we had art we had culture we had
music we had business and this was
meeting our own needs of our own
community but as we started to disperse
and go to the
south side the further south side the
south suburbs
we started to lose that capacity
we went downtown we went to the suburbs
and so we became
consumers
as opposed to producers yeah what we
have to return to our community is a
balance not just be consumption and not
just be consumer minded what can i buy
what can i own but what can i make what
can i produce and most importantly what
can i own
do you think that the mentality has
shifted you know i hear you talk about
consumption and producing do you think
that for our culture that it's
shifted to a consumption mentality for
far too long yeah for far too long but
i'll tell you pastor
is coming back yeah entrepreneurism
starting businesses
people are modeling themselves when we
look at uh the young athletes of the day
and others
young people are starting to see that
there are many roads in which they can
be they don't just have to be a rapper
or an athlete right to make it forward
yes they can be a business owner i'm
seeing young men
making garments and clothes and shoes
make making apparel making using their
craft and their talent to create even
technology-based solutions that we can
make i saw a young brother the other day
came up with some headphones for gamers
and so this is what we've got to get
into is this idea that if we can think
it up
we can dream it up we can build it up we
can make it up and we can own it up so
that we can start putting our own people
to work
and owning and creating the solutions
for our community exactly and that's
reason why you know i teach people and i
say to people all the time that
capitalism is important because it gives
us an opportunity to participate in the
economy it gives us a chance to
participate in free markets and and if
we can teach our people and that's why
i'm so thankful for you teaching the
classes getting people helping them with
their business getting them started
because if we're gonna solve some of the
issues of violence we have to start
participating in free market capitalism
well i'm so glad you said that because
it is the free market system the free
enterprise system and what we need more
than anything today
is people of good will yes to just do
business you know here we are in the
middle of a pandemic yeah you've seen
very little movement by business leaders
to address the solution from a business
they're all standing back hiding behind
government don't hide behind the
coattails of government
move forward with business solutions to
solve the problems that we have right
now we see that there's been this
so-called supply chain disruption why
because all these product products were
on a slow boat from china yeah exactly
and how did that happen when we used to
be in manufacturing distance right
around the corner from here is south
chicago avenue south chicago had
manufacturing from right here on the
corner yeah
all the way to the steel mills it was
nothing but small shops tool and dye
shops manufacturing shops they kept the
steel mills operating yeah they kept the
the auto companies operating so what do
we need now
the good news is
through advanced technologies 3d
printing 3d manufacturing smart we can
put a mat you can put a manufacturing
facility in your basement right you can
put it in a thousand square foot garage
there's no reason we shouldn't be making
and printing and designing and producing
and look you can put a saying on a
t-shirt and sell them for forty dollars
and make a few thousand dollars on the
weekend right right so get your hustle
on and start doing business but we also
need the business leaders of america
instead of hiding behind government and
hiding behind non-profits
do business yeah you know give some
contracts with all of the george floyd
pronouncements
all of the companies recognize their
lack
of following through on economic
commitments
here we are two years later where are
those commitments today what companies
are leading with real solutions for just
doing business giving people not a
handout
exactly but a hand up and bringing their
creativity their ingenuity their
capacity to supply into supply chains
and so now we've got an economy
that's going in two different directions
and the one is going in the direction
toward productivity and technology and
innovation we have to be a part of that
right that part of the economy and i
think we can yeah absolutely well
i think you said it you're on point as
always as i knew you would be i want to
thank you for uh all the work you do
um helping us get these businesses off
the ground helping people turn their
businesses around and
keep doing it well i can only do it
because you know project hood inspires
me
it inspires anybody i'm fortunate to
come from
four generations of entrepreneurs first
in arkansas my great-grandparents and
grandparents and then my parents here in
chicago and so i want to continue that
and i want my grandchildren my grandsons
i got three grandsons and i want them to
to be a part of this experience and know
that we can lead the way forward but
it's because of a project hood that
gives people inspiration that uh we can
make the change we need to make we just
as you've been asking for for
for a hundred days can we get some
business partners absolutely can we get
some folks to just do business can we
get some folks to sit down and talk
about what their needs are and allow us
to fill those needs in an economic
fashion we'll do the rest of the
workforce
i believe we're going to change
westwoodlawn we're going to be the
epicenter of what needs to happen in uh
these communities that are suffering
from violence and uh it could be a model
for what needs to be done across america
so thank you like it once was like like
it once was listen it's always a
blessing thank you it's always a
blessing to share with you all what's
going on on the south side of chicago
and even around america as it relates to
these urban centers i want to thank
foxes always for giving me this chance
to give you rooftop revelations and i
say every single day god bless you and
god bless america and until tomorrow
peace
you